I talk is about the real-time control of
electrical distribution grids and micro
grids it is joint work between my lab
which is in computer science and
communication systems at EPFL and and
the electrical engineering lab of
Professor Powell only at EPFL so they
would like to give credit to all the
people I've contributed to this work in
particular to the system aspect we're
interested in the real-time operation of
electrical distribution grids and I'll
give an example of a system called
Comelec that we have developed and then
I'll dive into one interesting
theoretical topic that comes out of this
research which I call here v-- control
we are motivated by the challenges that
are posed to electrical grids in general
whether transmission or distribution by
the penetration of large amounts of
distributed generation so those
challenges have been discussed already
in other talks but let me recall them
here the absence of inertia if there is
no rotating mass and the system behaves
in a very different way and controls
that have been developed for system with
rotating masses droop control are not
operational here and this is of course
exacerbated by the fact that the
generation itself becomes more random
but also by the fact that there are
there is an increase there's an increase
of on the load side of for example
charging stations a charging station for
supercharger of just six slots is 2
megawatts so that's a huge amount for
any grid so we have we receive signals
from all over the world saying that the
grids are not able to to support such
charging station without serious
reinforcement which is way too expensive
on the other hand we have mechanisms
that have also been this
for example by Sean Lane in the boot
camp about we have demon response that
can be used to alleviate a lot of those
problems and to some extend their
storage in the form of batteries that
are not able today to really do large
amounts of energy storage but that are
able to provide very fast flexible
response now the problem when you put
all of this together is how do you
orchestrate all those elements how do
you do the control how you do the
real-time operation that's the other
problem that we're addressing now one
point that's often forgotten is the main
grid and the stability of the global
system if you're in a country where at a
given point in time a large fraction the
majority of generation is created by
distributed renewables for example solar
panels you have a problem that those
resources don't participate in the
stability of the grid like traditional
big rotating masses are doing I mean the
rotor of a nuclear power is reacting to
subtle frequency changes and is
providing its natural inertia plus with
droop control a second artificial
inertia so this primary frequency
support which is also complemented in
many countries by secondary frequency
support AGC signals for example then you
have a problem I mean who provides this
Reserve if all the generation is
distributed one way to provide to give
the answer is to require that
distribution grid or micro grids behave
with respect to the system in the same
way as a generator does if if today you
buy a big generator and you connect it
to the grid in many countries that I
know of you will be required to provide
some minimal support and to announce a
dispatch plan you have to say tomorrow
from 12:00 to 12:15 use the amount of
power I will generate you go for the
market complex mechanisms for that but
the TSO that run the interconnection
know those values and planned their
operation in consequence what we would
like to do is to be able to do the same
thing with your micro grid let me give
an example of micro grid that's
motivated by some projects that we have
we're in an area
where we want to install a large
charging station and the point of
connection to the local grid is not able
to support it so we have a point of
connection that has a limit for example
zero five megawatts in powerful you may
have more subtle constraints like
maximum line currents on the line
voltage problems so what do you do when
you have such a problem where you can
complement your charging station with
local generation solar panels in many
countries and also perhaps a battery to
be able to have short time buffer to be
able to regulate the whole now if you do
this you are able to say to them a to go
to the market with your charging station
and say tomorrow between twelve and
twelve fifteen i will perhaps export
zero five megawatts because it's not a
peak period for me and i have a lot of
generation in the evening from 8:00 to
8:15 in contrast I may import the max
that I can import from here which may be
for example one megawatt so while doing
that you pull the number of problems for
the control of this entire operation to
microgreen the this is exacerbated by
the fact that the solar panels have a
large variability with time constants at
the order of a second so within a second
you can lose 60% of the production so
you need a control that's able to manage
all those power flows that's the problem
that we're addressing to address that we
have developed one system called Comelec
that manages a grid here I'm showing it
on a simple small grid but the system is
made scalable to manage grids of any
size it has a great agent which is a
piece of software running on the
embedded computer placed somewhere in
the grid that monitors the state of the
entire grid we use in our developed grid
micro p.m. use but we can use also a
classical PQ measurement systems that
need if they are synchronized the grid
agent monitors the state of the grid and
orchestrates the different resources by
speaking to resource agents that are
typically co-located on the inverters of
the other resources and while doing that
it tries to optimize a number
goals the primary goal being to make
sure that the local grid is working well
in the example I gave and we need to go
that would be the power flow at the
point of connection with the main grid
making sure this is not exceeded in
general there are more constraints there
might be lines that are a bit weak and
then you may want to make sure that the
maximum current flow on this line is
also not exceeding the ambassador limit
and also it integrates the all the
resources optimally if you're running a
charging station your goal is to charge
the card so you want to have the maximum
available power for for the cars but you
also want somehow to manage the battery
if you so what you will do with the
battery may depend on its state of
energy while doing that you may also
want to support the main grid and I'll
give an example in a minute how does the
grid agent orchestrate all this it needs
information it receives this information
from the resource agent so we have
developed a very very simple protocol
that simply repeats itself every 100
millisecond the resource agents respond
to the previous request of the grid
agent by sending some information about
their internal state and this
information is pure mathematical
abstract description we call them a PQ
profile picture profile is simply the
set of power if you think of active
power this is the interval of active
power that this resource is able to do
now based on its local state also a
virtual cost we call it virtual cost
because this is the cost that the
gradation will use in its optimization
function it may or may not be a monetary
cost and a belief function that manages
uncertainty that I will describe in a
minute why 100 millisecond well this is
the fastest that we are able to do if we
use p.m. use because it takes about 16
milliseconds to acquire a phaser with
p.m. use so we are here giving the the
fastest possible now it's also a good
value if we want to manage the
variability of solar PV s for example
that our order of a second so we could
be perhaps a bit less aggressive and run
every 200 or 500 milliseconds but being
fast makes our solar system much more
Robus so the system tries to be as
memory-less as possible
it receives advertisements from the
resources takes a local decision
implements them in between if things
changes if things change the resources
will send other advertisements and it
will correct other decisions I mentioned
the belief function that's an essential
part the belief function is a set valued
function that has the following meaning
if the grade a so this is something that
is exported by a resource agent if a
resource agent receives a request to
implement a certain power set point
we're an AC grid so we have both active
power and reactive power this one is
important for voltage and for minimizing
losses so if the gradient instructs a
resource to do a certain power set point
the resource will not usually do exactly
this for lots of reasons first we're in
the real world so anything we model is
never exactly how reality is second
there's major that is playing a role
here is an example of a PV panel there's
PV panel is operating at this point now
and we have technology to do ultra short
term prediction it's possible to predict
what will happen on a PV panel at a hora
horizon of two seconds for example
because this inertia in the class at our
passing and in the electronics so buys
very simple-minded data mining things
the resource agent of a PV panel is able
to do a prediction the prediction is
saying if I am operating here that's the
active power the worst case that can
happen is that if there is a cloud that
it can have that comes based on
historical data now if the great agent
normally a great agent instructs that
tries not to instruct anything to a
solar panel the only thing you can do
with this whole panel is to curtail it
you may want to reduce its production
you try to avoid this but sometimes it's
very efficient to allow the possibility
to curtail the solar panels for example
in many countries where solar is very
intermittent and concentrating in in the
summer you typically have overproduction
in a part of the summer but it still is
a canonical to do over product now you
have to manage this over production that
may create over voltage problem over
currents
so you may still want to curtail a solar
panel so if the grid aging says does not
curtail and it says to this resource
agent do this do this point where you
are now then we know that the the Billie
function captures the fact that it might
do with this or less because of nature
if in contrast the grid agent instructs
the solar panel to do this which is at
the minimum that the worst case happened
it could even do below then there's no
reason that the solar panel does less
than this so it's in that case the
belief set the output of this belief
function is a much smaller set than here
the belief function captures the
uncertainty due to nature but also the
uncertainty due to local inverter
control so here we are quasi real time
in the sense that we are operating at
say every 100 millisecond but before
that there are other things that are
happening at much faster timescale using
traditional control theory for example
the inverter is trying to make the power
output be that value but it does that by
controlling a current and the current
and the power depends on the current
tent above under tension the voltage of
the output of the system which you need
to measure and so there is usually a
slow control a controller that we don't
model in fact one of the key things we
want is not to model it other than every
resource has to know
and each controller and be able to put
bounds on the uncertainty generated by
this controller so that's a key element
that allows us to make the global system
manageable a great agent performs an
optimization function it tries to
minimize the total costs of the thing it
is managing of the grid it is managing
so it tries to satisfy the resources as
much as possible those are costs that
reflect the desired operating point of
the charging station but typically will
want to charge as much as possible the
cost of battery a battery may have a
target state of energy that is typically
given by dispatching exercise that is
none of the times came much slower than
what
and here if the target state of energy
of the battery is to be fooled to 80%
for example and the battery is currently
full at 50% then this battery would like
to absorb power so it will attach a cost
to any power setpoint that reflects this
it will give a negative or small cost to
absorbing large amounts of power and
very high cost to doing less than this
so this is how the greedy agent receives
indirectly information about the
hardware now know that the grid agent is
just doing a pure mathematics solving a
pure mathematical problem it doesn't
know anything in fact of the physic of
the system that it is managing other
than the equations of this physic it
also adds a penalty for the grid
quality-of-service yes question
what do I call it graded the gradation
is a piece of software that's running on
an embedded computer attached to our
grade somewhere typically at the point
close to the points to the computer that
receives the monitoring status of the
grid it's just a piece of software that
runs the grid yeah just like in your
computer you have a screen and a
keyboard and below that you have a piece
of software called the operating system
so what we're doing is an operating
system for the grid now it's running the
grid in real-time what an operator a
human operator is doing he's going to
the market to do for example a dispatch
going to do my grid tomorrow will
produce 1 megawatt between 12 and 2015
this is outside the scope of my toe
other than the side effect of how do i
implement this dispatch plan in this
grid so the goal of this is to implement
a dispatch frame that was this one this
one yes it is the it is the value at
started during this cycle of operation
that is based on the advertisements that
the gradation has received so changes
over indirectly through the cost
function that the battery will will give
so the feedback goes by the physical
system if the battery charges I mean the
state of energy of a battery moves very
slowly so if the battery is charging its
state of energy increases depending on
the goal set by the dispatcher and for
the battery the variations in the state
of energy of the battery will correspond
to variation in the cost advertised by
the battery to the great agent so it's
an essential component because we want
to build software for the gradation
that's unique one single piece of
software for all greedy agents that we
do it's always the same it doesn't know
that it's controlling a battery for exam
the resource agent is Hardware specific
but the resource agent is also fairly
dumb it just translates things from one
language to
and a third term in the equation that
the in the function that the gradation
is minimizing is the relation to the
Dispatch point for example if there is a
dispatch plant that instructs for a
given value of power exchanged at the
point of connection with with the main
grid then any deviation from this is
penalized by a penalizing function here
of course that's the easy part of the
equation now the difficult part is
admissibility like in any control system
and in minimizing how do we minimize
this in fact we don't do a minimization
because we're acting fast we simply do a
gradient step so we compute a direction
of the gradient and the only thing we
minimize is the gain how much do we
what's the number that we multiply the
gradient with this we find the optimal
number in this direction but the
difficult thing is admissibility is this
set point admissible because we I mean
all the system is made for grids where
they post potential problems if there is
no limit on the voltage and the current
and the power flow you don't need all
that stuff right so there is a problem
and the problem is admissible attea we
want to compute a set point that is
feasible in some sense we more precisely
we have to make sure that the operation
of the grid is okay for any true value
of what will result of instructing this
that is in the belief function so we
know if we instruct the grid to do X it
will do something that we don't know
exactly but we were able to put down the
round what it was into so we have a
robust optimization problem if we want
not truly a robust optimization problem
because we we just do gradient descent
but this is the major theoretical thing
we have to work so I'll talk more about
how we do this in in the second part
here is so we have currently two grids
that are running this system and four
more that are in deployment this is the
very first that is RTP a family in
Switzerland in in the lab of Professor
Paolini this is the power system lab
it's an isolated building because it's a
Power Systems building in case it blows
up
rest of the campus is still okay the
grid there is a reproduction of a
benchmark of C gray so professor Paul
and his team has built in in this part
of the building the actual the actual
grid so with the cable there's more than
one kilometre of cable at 400 volts the
schematic is given here this grid has
many more things that are not all shown
in the in the results a char here we are
controlling the sort of solar panels
that are on the roof and on the under
wall there is a battery a fairly small
battery 25 kilowatt hour and 25 kilowatt
that is we don't use a battery for
storing energy from one day to the next
we'll use it really to manage the
uncertainty of a dispatch plant to use
it as a buffer to be able to to have
optimal operation we also have what we
call a flex house which is a big thermal
law that represents a building with
seven rooms that uses a heating system
we also have a heat pump fuel cell and
all the light but I will not show a
result here is an example of a trace
measured on this grid this is showing
here a dispatch plant so the green line
here is the dispatch plant now it's at
time intervals of roughly five minutes
and we went we assumed here that during
this period the grid was exporting and
importing nothing then there was a
period where it was having negative
injection that means it's consuming and
and this is what has been typically done
in advance by before the operation runs
now what is happening in real time is
that as so first we need to follow this
dispatch plan which is already the
constable change for the global system
if all the micro grids are significant
fraction of micron is operated in this
way there is much more it's much easier
to forecast what will happen and to
control the entire system but we do also
primary three
and sister Paul this is the frequency
that's measured by the p.m. use one of
the p.m. use that connects to the main
grid
in Europe it's 50 Hertz so when the
frequency is larger than 50 Hertz that
means there is excess of production of
generation in the continental a grid of
Europe and all generators in Europe
should try to consume to try to produce
less or every load that can participate
should like should consume more so this
is we see that this is exactly what is
happening here at the same interval we
see in blue is in fact the actual
implementation of what the grid does and
we see that it is doing slightly less
than it's dispatch burn so with this
system we have a grid that can be
foreseeable and can also react to local
imbalances to keep the global grid in
operation a side effect of this mode of
operation is we need a reliable
computing infrastructure I think the
autonomous cars when they have fixed
their software problems will come also
to the same conclusion when they stop
killing people because of software
inefficiencies we will worry about them
not killing people because of the
computer going down so we have thought
and this about this and to some extent
done number of things to mitigate the
effect our grid is not as bad as a car
in the sense that of course there are
protections that continue to exist in a
grid we are controlling the grid but the
protection is not done by the widest
system if there is an excess power flow
somewhere something will trip what we
want is to avoid the tripping we use a
duplication of everything we can
duplicate we duplicate the network there
are many efforts on duplicating network
here called as the dead networking group
of ITF that is doing that the TSM group
of I Triple E 802 dot one we do
something that is are fairly simple that
works for UDP flows only there are
theoretical issues in duplicating TCP
flows a side-effect with congestion
controls that are not well understood
now today we believe it doesn't work but
we do that for all the UDP flows that
that are done here and then we also
address the reliability of the grid
agent itself by duplicating it we
duplicate it and by doing active
duplication traditional forms of
duplication in the context of smart grid
is hot standby or code standby servers
but if you have intermittent fault so if
you have crashes that you want to
recover quickly within 100 millisecond
this is typically not compatible so what
we do is run to grid agents in parallel
use multicast so that they receive all
the measurements multicast is done
routinely in that context because
typically while we're running this are
also SCADA that's monitoring everything
we do so all measurements all requests
all set points are typically sent to
multiple computers so that comes for
free and then the active replication
means that multiple controllers are
sending requests to the resource agents
now if you do that and there is no loss
then there's no problem but of course if
there's no loss you wouldn't worry
perhaps perhaps so much about
duplicating so you need this form of
consensus so that if there are multiple
agents ingredient that are computing
things and one of them has one
measurement missing that they take
compatible and I can't believe it five
minutes ok so we do a lightweight form
of consensus that has bounded latency
then I will dive into very quickly into
the main theoretical problem we have
here of the admissibility test
which mathematically can be represented
from the power flow equation so V here
is the electrical state the state of the
of the can you give me two more minutes
okay thank you very much
the electrical state of the grid that's
the complex voltage phasors are at every
node is mapped by the well known load
flow equations into the power injections
when I say injection it's positive or
negative depending whether you are
generator of along this load flow is
quadratic and the inverse problem
finding the electrical state of a grid
given the power injection is known as
the load flow problem it's a nasty
problem that are zero one or multiple
solutions here now the problem that the
grid agent has is we don't know exactly
what the injections will be but we know
the set in which they reside and given
the set in which they reside we would
like to we are controlling in fact the
state of the grid by the power
injections but there's not a one-to-one
mapping from the state to the from the
injections to the state of the grid so
can we still control through s and make
sure that the grid satisfy the voltage
and ambassador constraints here
mathematically we formalize that by
saying I say that a domain my
uncertainty set for example a domain of
the power injections is able to control
this grid to remain in a set V in short
is a dominant V control if the following
is true whenever we start in V and we
are sure that the power injections
remain in s and the trajectory in V
space is continuous we must stay in the
state V this is formally the the
mathematical formula so we'd like to
find to ask what the grid agent decides
for a set point X it has to know whether
the belief belief function of X is a set
that has this property on now of course
for this tube to be true you need to be
V control you need that all the power
injections are feasible we know that
from power flow theory that
maybe injections that are not feasible
if you do that that's of course is
stupid but I skip quickly here this I'm
sure that it's not sufficient being
having a low flow solution is not
sufficient even having a unique load
flow solution is not sufficient so you
can find counter examples I give one
here where you have a unique load flow
solution but depending where you start
you end up in a non feasible state or
now there is however a simple theorem
that says this thing here if the set of
control states of electrical States is
open in the classical sense of the usual
topology and they set here and if the
setup or injection is also open and if
there is a unique load flow solution for
every s then there must be a V control
that is very specific to the load flow
equation this result is not true for any
system is very specific to the flow
equation and in fact it's related to non
singularity if that happens all the
points in V such that F of V is in s
unnecessary non-senior and this is due
to another result that is this one here
which says that if a set of electrical
state is a domain of uniqueness that
means there are load flow equations are
in injection injection a one-to-one
mapping from the set to the set of
injection then necessarily all those
points are non senior the converse is
true locally by the inverse function
theorem and this is true here simply
because we have a quadratic function if
we would have a cubic function that
would not be true but since we have
accurate different so is true for all
systems that are quadratic functions so
non singularity comes for free and
follows from uniqueness then I will
conclude on that by saying that here is
how we solve our problem we solve our
problem by we are a given set that we
want to know whether it's admissible so
we try to construct an electrical state
a set of electrical states that
satisfies the voltage and ambassador
constraints that is a domain of
uniqueness will you
contraction mapping to make sure that
for every s we have a solution thank you
I see Bruce nervous but I'm finishing
here and such that the all the load flow
injection all the injections given by
the load flow equations are in the set
well so we solve this and I will let you
read the references that will give later
to find out more details on how we use
this algorithm
concretely by using contraction mappings
to build such sets every big resource
that we control we will not do that in a
in a house yes so what we do typically
you want to you don't want to do this to
control your boiler and let your PV yes
we then we can do a resource agent for
your PV if you want to control all of
them yes yes so we of course this system
works even if we control only part of
the state we have what we call a shadow
agent that is monitoring at points where
we have no control which is monitoring
the electrical state and is the same
story as with forecasting the PV with a
shadow agent you can forecast for the
next 100 millisecond or even one second
or the bounce that will happen there so
this is highly predictable at this time
scheme